[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much it's much
appreciated um
the last time i was surrounded like this
was
i think it was that a demonstration
anyways it's lovely to be here um in
this amazing building
and in this amazing city and well also
in this amazing country we've had a
wonderful time in australia so far this
is the second time i've been here and
it's gone extraordinarily well both
times and i don't know
why that is exactly but something's
working and so i appreciate that very
much it's very good of you to take
the time out this afternoon and to make
the take the trouble and to come and
listen to
an hour and a half of ideas that's a
strange thing for you to choose to do
but
personally i'm very happy about it so i
think we'll get
right to it i want to cover a fair bit
of psychological territory today
i'm going to try to integrate four of
the rules from 12 rules for
for life the first rule is
stand up straight with your shoulders
back and it's a
it's really a description of the
ancient nature of hierarchies their
almost universal existence among living
creatures
and the fact that you have
extraordinarily
ancient and profound neurological
systems
that really govern they govern your
psyche
that process hierarchical information
it's it's it's such an important
psychological fact to know i i don't
know if there's another
psychological biological fact that's
more crucial than that
it's the serotonin system is the system
that tracks
hierarchical information and it's so
crucial that it actually
sets up your brain in utero so it's it's
the master control system of the brain
if you thought about the brain as a
symphony which is actually a pretty good
way of thinking about it
from a metaphorical perspective the the
serotonin system would definitely be the
conductor
so so there's rule one and then there's
there's rule seven which is
do what is meaningful not what is
expedient
and it's also at least in part a
neurological chapter because one of the
things i learned
really a lot from reading russian
neuropsychology strangely enough the
russians had great neuropsychologists
um was that the
the sense of meaning the sense of
engagement
that characterizes life when life is
progressing in the manner that you would
like it to progress
is actually an instinct it's not a it's
not a cognitive
phenomenon it's not a second order
consequence of thought it's
way deeper than that it's an
extraordinarily
profound instinct and so that's really
worth thinking about
assuming you know as you might that um
we're adapted creatures and that our
instincts
guide us in the world so that we can
survive and so that we can reproduce and
and so that we can exist over long
periods of time
the fact that an instinct of that depth
exists and that it's associated with the
sense of vital engagement
in being let's say is a good indication
as good an indication as there is
that there's something truly real about
it and i would say
that might even be more important than
the knowledge of the
of the role that the serotonin system
plays in
adjudicating hierarchical position
because
you know we tend to think of meaning as
something that people create as a
secondary consequence through thinking
or through philosophy or something like
that and
when we think that it's easy to
criticize it it's easy to become cynical
about it it's easy to lose faith in it
but when you understand that it actually
is a much deeper phenomenon than that
and that the cognitive elements the
philosophical elements are sort of like
well they're like the fronds on the top
of the pond on
on a plant system that has unbelievably
deep roots that go way down into the
water it's
much it's it's it's much there's
something about that that's much
firmer and more solid and and i i think
that
i think the evidence that meaning is an
instinct
a deep deep instinct is overwhelming i i
don't think that
popular knowledge has caught up with
that i mean the research is it's not
new but it's been done i would say in
the main in the last
30 years or so and mostly by
psychobiologists like people who are
really on the hard science end of
psychology and their work is difficult
it's it's technically difficult it
involves a lot of neurobiology
neuroanatomy psychopharmacology it's
it's hard work it's hard going
but it's unbelievably useful um i have
two books in my reading list by the way
um at jordanb peterson.com if you're
interested in this sort of thing one is
by a man named yak pancep who is an
absolute genius he died a few years ago
unfortunately
i think he deserved a nobel prize and
you never know maybe he'll still get one
um because he discovered whole circuits
mammalian circuits that no one knew
existed so for example pancep
outlined a play circuit in mammals
there's a separate biological play
circuit in mammals and like it's a big
deal to discover an entire new
neurological continent right
that's a big discovery and that wasn't
all he did it was one of many things he
did
so the book is called affective
neuroscience
which is a rather intimidating title it
means emotional neuroscience and
you wouldn't think you'd necessarily
pick up a book on neuroscience
you know for a light read but it's
actually a very readable book it's it's
the the people who work on emotions in
neuroscience
tend to be a little bit more romantic
for scientists and they're a little more
interested in story and
and narrative and so he tells he tells a
whole sequence of stories in affective
neuroscience and it's a very readable
book and it's a great book i would
if you're if you're interested in
psychology um i would highly recommend
it
and then there's another book there
called the neural psychology of anxiety
which is written by a man named jeffrey
gray
and that that damn thing's that's hard
that that's like a six month slog that
book
i mean he he was he was an absolutely
he had an absolutely encyclopedic
knowledge
of animal behavior and neurobiology and
psychopharmacology and
uh like i don't know how many references
are in that book 2400 something like
that and
he read them you know he didn't just
cite them and not only did he read them
he also
understood them and integrated them and
so it's a tough read but
man i tell you there's really something
to that so
a lot of what i'm going to talk to you
about tonight although not all of it is
derived from those books and and so i
would recommend them if you'd like to go
more deeply into these sorts of topics
and so
um that's rule seven do what is
meaningful
not what is expedient because meaning is
an instinct and meaning is the instinct
that guides you in life
across the totality of life right what's
expedient
that's what you might want to do right
now in an impulsive sense right because
you're driven forward by
oh anger or anxiety or frustration or
disappointment or despair
some sort of one-eyed motivational
monster that's got you in its grip
that really isn't considering everything
at once right like considering
your life tomorrow or your life next
week or your family's life or
or maybe your maybe even your well-being
half an hour from now you know because
you lash out in anger and it's
you can you know people do that it's
understandable
sometimes it's even necessary but it's
not wise
generally and the instinct for meaning
seems to be
a consequence of the integration of all
of those underlying motivations and
emotions
with social being and then the
manifestation of something like the
proper pathway
forward and so and you need that because
you need to know
how to move forward in life because you
need to move forward in life you need to
act in life
and the other thing that's i suppose
part and parcel of let's say 12 rules
for life is the insistence upon
action as of primary import
we're not fundamentally creatures who
passion
passively perceive the objective world
that that's not the goal of our
perceptual systems it's not the goal of
our memory
the reason that you have memories isn't
to remember the past
the reason you have memories is so that
if something bad happened to you in the
past
you can figure out what it was that was
bad and you can figure out why it
happened
and then you can not do it again in the
future
right it's very practical and it's the
same on the positive end of the spectrum
if
good things happen to you in the past
then conceivably
duplicating whatever you did to get
those good things to happen
could have them happen again in the
future so it's
it's practical memory and it's it's
oriented towards
action and it's oriented towards like
the quality of your life
not to the description of the objective
world even though that may be a useful
thing to do
at least under some circumstances so
that's
rule seven rule eight is tell the truth
or at least
don't lie and originally that rule was
just tell the truth
but then i thought about it which you
should do if the rule is tell the truth
and um i thought no you better be
careful about about
putting forward a rule like that because
to tell the truth
implies that you know the truth
and you don't know the truth because
you're too ignorant to know the truth
like you don't know the truth about
anything fully right if you push your
knowledge out far enough
if i ask you why about something you're
doing
enough times it's usually only three or
four times by the way
you're out answers you don't know and if
it's same generally if i ask you how
something works like how does a
helicopter work
well you know the little whirly things
spin and i don't know this
thing like rock-like entity rises into
the air it's
like really that's a pretty sad
explanation
and and you know that's kind of the
level of detail that you have about a
lot of things so
you know you're pretty you're pretty
ignorant like everyone else it's just so
well there's just so many how there's
just too many things
to know you know and they're detailed
and difficult
and so you get by with pretty shallow
understanding of
of most things and so you can't really
tell the truth
but i think you can not lie
you know and that's not even the same as
not being wrong because of course you're
also going to be wrong and
you have stupid theories too and they're
not even necessarily lies
a lie is when you know that what you're
saying is not true
and you say it anyways that's a lie and
and it's a lie that you've decided
yourself on the basis of your own
knowledge
that's a lie you've decided that that's
your own moral judgment and so
i rewrote the rule to suggest that
it's not a good idea to
say things that you know not to be true
and i would say by the way
as a practical issue it's also a worse
idea to write
things that you don't think are true
because you know your your your your
mind is organized at
the highest level of abstraction in
language
and and it's important that your mind is
organized because if you're not
organized then
you're disorganized and then things
don't go well for you in the world
just like they don't go well for
anything that's disorganized and so
you have to be very careful with what
you say
and what you write writing especially
because it's like
it's focused speaking it's focused
speech right it
takes more intense thinking so in some
sense writing is even deeper than
speaking
but you don't want to speak things that
you believe to be untrue and you
certainly don't want to write them
because that
changes you and it changes you in the
direction
of the deception that you're undertaking
while you do the speaking or the writing
and you might think now i can write
whatever i want and i can just leave it
be
but that's not true and the reason for
that in part is because your knowledge
is shallow
and so if you take rather shallow
knowledge and then you write something
detailed that's false you end up
convincing yourself in all sorts of ways
that you don't even notice that what you
wrote that was a lie was true
and then you're stuck with that and it's
it's not stuck with it
psychologically exactly although it's
also that it's stuck with it
neurologically
because when you learn things and you
make new connections you
you re you change the structure of your
brain
and then that's that i mean you know
you're it's plastic to some degree but
you're messing around with your
psychophysiology
and that's a bad idea and you know it's
a bad idea because
you kind of know like everybody knows
that
if you want to get through the world if
you want to get from point a to point b
if you want to get to wherever you're
going it'd be good to have a map
and it'd probably be good to have a map
that isn't full of holes
and errors because otherwise
you're not going to get to where you're
going you might not even know where you
are
to begin with and that seems like a bad
plan
if you're going to undertake a journey
and you are going to take
undertake a journey because your life is
a journey
so pathologize your speech
then you pathologize the systems that
guide you
and then that relates back to rule seven
which is well you have an instinct for
meaning
let's say and it can guide you and you
need it
and then if you pathologize it by
introducing
material that you know to be untrue then
you distort and and and warp
and and and and pathologize
the very structure
that the the very feeling that you need
to place
yourself firmly in the world and then
you can't rely on yourself
and this is a very bad idea because you
need to rely on yourself
especially in situations of crisis you
know when you have difficult decisions
to make and it's
it's like well it's not obvious whether
i should go right or whether i should go
left right because
there's a lot riding on both decisions
and so you're sweating it out
or maybe you have three or four
decisions to make at the same time it's
like
you can talk to your friends and all
that and but you
you're the guy in the final analysis man
it comes down to you
and if you can't trust yourself because
you've filled yourself up with nonsense
then
you'll make the wrong decision and then
hey maybe you'll pay for it for the rest
of your life
and and maybe you'll deserve to as well
and so
it's very you know you hear now and then
at university students say
uh undergraduates they say well it just
i just write what the professor wants
to hear and then i get a good grade it's
like
first of all most professors aren't that
corrupt
there are corrupt professors but most of
them are not that corrupt
you have to be pretty damn corrupt
before you go that far before a student
will hand you something
that's well crafted and well thought
through and you'll actually punish them
for it you've gone way off the
malevolent end of the academic spectrum
when you do that now
you know maybe you're a bit biased and
you'll give them a b plus instead of an
a
and it's not like that's particularly
forgivable but it's not a catastrophe
but so i think it's a bit cynical on the
part of the undergraduates
usually but more importantly it's like
what are you going to do you're going to
do your whole four-year degree and all
you're going to do is write what you
think your professors
want to hear and you think you're going
to come out educated you think you're
going to come out
the person you were when you went in
it's like no
you're not because you've rewritten a
different self and you've practiced
deceit with regards to your highest
moral faculty right your capacity for
articulated speech
you've practiced that for four years and
so then definitely when you come out
you're way worse than you were when you
went in and that's not
education that's that's that's the
antithesis of education
better not to be there better to lay
bricks
right and not and i have nothing by the
way against bricklayers
way to be bricklayers as far as i'm
concerned but at least they can lay a
straight brick wall and it will stand up
and there's something honest and solid
about that
much better that than to go and produce
written material that that that you
don't
that your soul isn't in that's that's
what the damn education system is for
insofar as it's not you know there to
train you professionally
it's to develop you psychologically and
spiritually and to turn you into a
citizen
you know into a competent human being
you compromise that
because of expediency an excuse usually
it's it's a very bad idea i would highly
recommend against
never doing it and i would say the same
thing at work whenever
it's very psychologically dangerous to
say things you know not to be true so
and and in part it is because it warps
that
instinct for meaning and so you need
that instinct for meaning too so
and we should get this real straight why
do you need it
well you need it because life is really
really difficult
right i mean people have a rough time of
it there's
plenty of suffering in life and everyone
is going to encounter it
right there you don't you know you learn
this as a clinical psychologist and
you know this generally you know unless
you're an extraordinarily fortunate
person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long
and and really talk to them and get
beneath the surface until you find
you know there's a tragedy or two or
three or ten lurking
not very far beneath the surface someone
in the family is very ill
there's a childhood history of extreme
pathology
alcoholism somewhere in the family maybe
a touch of insanity
someone has cancer you know someone some
an older relative is dying
there's financial trouble there's
economic trouble
there's marital trouble it's like life
is
trouble and now you know it that doesn't
mean it's all
trouble but man it's trouble and
sometimes it's it's a
lot of trouble and sometimes it's so
much trouble that
you can you can barely stand it and and
you see that because people you know
people get depressed and they commit
suicide and
the reason they do that is because they
think not being is better than being
and that's quite the decision you know
so and and
it's not that uncommon among people who
are depressed and so it's it's
it's a very it's a very important thing
to consider and it and it isn't just a
matter of depression
and suicide that's bad enough but you
know if you're unhappy
because your suffering has pushed you
past the point of
your ability to cope then there's all
sorts of other things that can happen to
you
that aren't directed towards you you can
become cynical and you can become bitter
and you can become cruel and you can
become
narcissistic and deceitful and arrogant
and
and it's like everything's for you and
then you're out for revenge
that's a nice one i don't know against
who but maybe
everyone maybe even including you
because you're not happy about the rule
you've played in generating your own
misery
i mean there's a lot of darkness
underneath the suffering and
so and and that's that's an ever-present
existential danger for human beings you
know
we're aware of the future we're aware of
our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us
truly unique truly conscious in a way
that no other creature is
and capable of things that no other
creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load we're the only
creatures that have to
always contend with the fact that we're
finite
and that everyone we know is in the same
position
that allied with the suffering and so
that's there all the time
and and you know even even in in the
brightest moments in some sense
you know in in in renaissance paintings
in in still life they used to put a
momento
momento mori often in the in the still
life
like a skull somewhere in the corner or
sometimes sometimes
in in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see the skull if you were
standing like right beside the painting
instead of dead on but the idea was to
always remember you know that
everything that exists is tainted or
touched with the
with the with the with it with the taint
of mortality
and you know that's rough but there's
some useful things in it it keeps you
awake and it keeps you focused if you're
careful
but it also does indicate to you if you
think about it
the necessity of having a meaning in
your life because
because if it's true intrinsically that
life has this unbearable element of
suffering which seems to be completely
in in what would you say indisputable as
far as i'm concerned
and it's worse than that too because
it's not just suffering it's suffering
contaminated with malevolence right it's
bad enough to have something bad happen
to you and
it's likely that that'll happen but it's
even worse for you to do it to yourself
and to know that you did it
that's rough and it's also
extraordinarily rough to be betrayed by
someone else
or you know tyrannized by your own
culture
and so and that's that's not just
suffering that's like
unnecessary and pointless suffering
that's been directed at you by something
that
wants that to happen and so both of
those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and
we have to deal with them at every level
of reality and you need
something to you need something to push
back against that
it's not optional if that's the default
position and i think it's the default
position
like a meaningless life isn't
meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence that's
not good and
and if that's acted out you know that's
the other thing if that's acted out and
i've read
the accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very vicious turn into the
darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make
everything in the world suffer for the
outrage of its existence man i mean
that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
states take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life
overwhelms them and they turn and they
turn in a very bad direction and then
they make everything that's already bad
way worse
and we're very very inventive at such
things
and so that's not good unless that's the
path you want that's a bad idea you need
an alternative and that's meaning and
then rule 10 well that's
be precise in your speech and so i'm
going to
weave those together and see what we can
come up with
as something like a general theory of
meaning
that's really what i've been working on
i would say for 35 years something like
a general theory of meaning and
so i'm going to see if i can deliver the
whole damn thing in 35 minutes
so which i've never really been able to
manage but i've had a lot of practice so
maybe this is the night
so okay so the first thing i want to
tell you about is
a little bit about how you perceive
things because um it's very important to
to know how you perceive things and you
don't perceive very much
by the way because well there's a lot
of the world way more than you can
possibly imagine and there's not that
much of you
and so you're a lot of information is
coming in through a very narrow channel
and
it isn't easy given the fact that all
that information exists
it isn't easy to figure out how to
narrow that channel so that
the information you get is the
information that you need
information you need that also gives you
a grip on the world right it has to be
practically useful
true and practically useful something
like that it's a very
very very very difficult problem to
solve
and a lot of it you don't even you don't
even really solve because you can't
um it's too complicated you solve it by
doing what you're doing right now
for example so here you are in this
unbelievably beautiful building
and i read today a little bit about it
and today it would cost about a billion
dollars to build this building and so
you're sitting here and and you're all
sitting here peacefully and
you're all pointing in the same
direction right and we're all basically
doing the same thing and we're doing it
peacefully and
we can all all focus on the same thing
and we had to invest a billion dollars
for that to be able to happen
and so part of you think about that is
that part of
the way your society solved the problem
of the complexity of the world for you
was by investing a billion dollars in
what 15
how long did it take to construct this
place 15 years something like that maybe
it was longer
so that you could sit here in relative
comfort and peace and tranquility
and concentrate on something that's very
focused maybe something of beauty
something of artistic merit something of
intellectual merit and that the rest of
the world
wasn't there so you didn't have to worry
about it
and then and that's not all it's not
just that you're here in this building
and
the chairs aren't falling apart and the
the floor is reliable and the electrical
lights work and the sound
quality is good and like all the
technology is working and there's people
beetling away in the background like mad
constantly
everywhere making sure that those
impossible things keep happening so that
you don't have to be distracted
but then you're also sitting with people
who are roughly
like you you know roughly like you
enough so that when they come into a
venue like this
they know enough to sit down in the
seats and face
forward and not turn around and look at
the person behind them which would make
them very nervous
right which would be an indication that
that person isn't playing the same game
as everyone else and so
god only knows what they're up to
because you just wouldn't want that
right you wouldn't want the guy in front
of you turning around and just
looking at you for the next 90 minutes
and well it's worth
it's worth thinking about why like what
what
are you thinking about you know you know
you you're going to be sitting there
looking like this your eyes are going to
be darting around and maybe you're going
to be nudging someone
you know pointing at this person because
maybe they have some idea of what this
person is up to
because you don't and the problem is if
you don't know what that person is up to
then they could be up to anything and
anything is a lot of things to be up to
and and you don't want people to be up
to anything
you want them to be up to the one or two
things they're supposed to be up to
while they're with you in this narrow
place that you occupy
right and that and that's well that's
sort of the hallmark of a civilized and
socialized person is
when when we interact under 90 percent
of conditions 99 of conditions
you show me your persona it's just a
very narrow slice of yourself
and i show you mine at the bank say or
or you know at the grocery store when we
pass each other casually in the street
we nod and say hi and you naught and say
hi or
we just walk by peacefully and like
we're seething with complexity and we
don't let any of that out and the reason
for that is
we don't want anybody else to let any of
it out either right
so we keep ourselves simplified and and
and we we build our architecture for
that and so you know you come into a
building like this
and the building tells you what to do
the chairs are all aligned
the chairs say sit on me right the
chairs are all facing the same way in
kind of a semi-circle and they say
face the stage and there's a stage and
so
you come in here and all the perceptual
problems are solved
and so there's all this technology and
there's all this expense and then
there's the shared culture
that enables you to know that this is
something like a theatrical experience
and so what you do at a theatrical
experience is
come together in as a group and remain
silent but attentive participating in
that manner
and watch and listen to the main
performance
and you all know that it's part of the
shared culture and so that shared
culture is also
enabling you to perceive what you're
perceiving right now as a protective
mechanism
and that's part of a broader shared
sense of civilization and it's dependent
on a shared government and
and then there's other forms of
protection you know i mean
while we're not there's the sun isn't
shining on us too brutally because we
have a roof
and we're not in danger of warfare
because you have borders and you have an
armed forces and you have policemen and
it's like
christ there's just things going on
around you like
mad to ensure that you can sit here
so peacefully and and so much as if
the world isn't a complex place for an
hour and a half
and do something this focused and so
that's partly how you solve the
perceptual problem
you don't see the world that much you
you screen a lot of it out now
there's a good indication good
illustration of this um
a psychologist named dan simon did this
famous experiment
which he called gorillas in our midst
and some of you know about it but i'm
gonna go over it because
it's such a fun experiment to talk about
because it's so ridiculous
and so illuminating and because it's so
relevant to what i want to continue
talking to you about so
here's the deal you go into dan simon's
lab
he was at harvard 20 years ago when he
did this and he was interested in this
phenomena
called change blindness you know you see
those kids books sometimes where there's
picture one and picture two
and you're supposed to look at picture
one and then look at picture two and see
what's changed
it's actually hard you know you look at
picture one you say well i saw that
and then you look at picture two and
it's different
but you can't see the differences and
you have to really
compare back and forth before you can
check out the differences and that's
what perception is like is
you're very blind to change way more
than you think
and and way more than anybody thought
before simon did his experiments and so
he did this crazy experiment um so
here's the setup
video camera set up in front of a
elevator bank right and so the camera
would be
here the elevator bank would be about
here so you know it's pretty pretty
close up shot
there's six people participating three
of them dressed in black three of them
dressed in white
the the white team has a basketball the
black team has a basketball
they fill the whole screen so it's not
like they're way over in the corner this
high and you can barely see them they
they fill up the whole screen you can
you can detect their facial figures it's
it's close
shot you see their whole body but it's
clear there's no tricks in it
and uh you sit there and you're the
experimental subject and
and the the uh the the psychologist
or or his assistant says uh okay here's
your task
and you're there to be focused on a task
apparently because you're in a
university and you're in a lab and you'd
expect to be focused on a task and
so you're already primed for that and
you're willing to go along with it to be
obedient but to be a good sport let's
say that's better than obedient and you
want to do a good job because
it's intimidating to be in the lab like
that and so you want to
you want to do a good job of whatever
you're supposed to do um unless you're a
troublemaker and you're probably not
because you wouldn't go into the lab to
begin with if you were a troublemaker
so so simon says um simon says
says count the number of times
like the white team is going to throw a
basketball back and forth variety of
ways
three minutes just count how many times
they manage it and they're going to
bounce it and throw it directly and all
that and
so the black team and the white team
start to mill around
in on the video and they're tossing the
basketball back and forth and
you're watching the uh basketball very
intently
with the central part of your vision now
the central part of your vision is very
high resolution
and you can tell this it's pretty easy
i'll show you
i don't know now this probably won't
work because i think the
i think the theater is too big to do it
but we could try it
i guess so look at my finger
right but but pay attention to my face
now that's hard because usually when you
pay attention to something you look
right at it but i don't want you to do
that i want you to pay attention to my
finger
and look at my face and what should
happen except perhaps for those of you
who are quite
a distance at the back is that you'll
notice that you actually can't see
my facial features so for example if i
look at
even somebody in the third row if i look
directly at you
i can see your facial features fine i
can tell you have glasses
i can't tell if you're male or female i
can't distinguish you
from the chair and it has nothing to do
with you
[Laughter]
right but like you don't have to move
very far away from central vision before
it becomes extremely low resolution and
so that's how your visual system is set
up
high resolution in the middle low
resolution as you move towards the
periphery until like out here
i actually can't tell how many i mean i
know how many fingers i have
well five if you include the thumb but i
can't see them
if i move them i can see them better
because that's one of the ways your
visual system overcomes its limitations
is that it's better at seeing movement
than things that are
that are stable and that's because well
if you're watching something and
something suddenly moves you know off to
the right
it might be a good idea for you to shift
your attention just to see what it is
and so that's a trick your visual system
uses but mostly it's
it's foveal vision and it's a very very
small part of your visual field
and it's extremely heavily
neurologically innervated
in the visual cortex a lot of cells are
devoted to that tiny area
in the middle of your vision to make it
as high resolution as possible and it
might be nice
um eagles have two fovea by the way they
can see better than human beings
their eyes bald eagles their eyes are as
big as human beings and they can see
better than we can they're the only
animals that can do that
they have two fovea but you you can't
have
that high resolution vision across the
entire span
of your eyes because then your head
would have to be this big
to carry that much brain around and
obviously that would be hideous
and also counterproductive so so we do
the best
we can and what it means is that we're
blind to a lot of things that we don't
think we're blind to
so anyways so you're playing dan simon's
game and you're counting
the number of times that the basketball
is tossed back and forth between the
white team and he says
how many times and you say being a good
experimental
participant you say 16. and
you're right and he says you're right
and you think oh good i'm smart enough
to participate
in a psychological experiment you you
feel good about yourself you know it's a
little
self-respect boost let's say because you
passed the test
and then simon says um
did you see anything out of the ordinary
and you say most of you some people
notice
most of you say no um what do you mean
and simon says well the gorilla
did you see the gorilla and and you
think well
what do you mean did i see the gorilla
like there was no damn gorilla there's a
i'd see a gorilla right if you're if
we're watching me on stage and the
gorilla came out here
you'd see it maybe
maybe as it turns out it might depend on
what the gorilla was doing
but any in any case so simon rewinds the
tape as you watch it
so that there's no tricks and he says
don't don't count the balls this time
just watch
so it's a different command right so you
have a different aim now you're pursuing
a different value structure he says
just watch and he rewinds it and sure
enough you see the gorilla
coming out backwards and being in the
middle and and then going off to the
side and then he replays it for you and
a minute and a half into the
three-minute video
in waltz is this damn gorilla it's a guy
because they didn't have a gorilla for
obvious reasons
uh ethics committees wouldn't allow them
to use a real gorilla
and he's a big guy he's not
a small chimpanzee type ape he's
six foot four and he saunters out there
and beats his chest like for four
seconds right in the middle of the
screen which you might think you'd see
since it's right in the middle of the
screen and
then he saunters off to the side and you
don't see it
and the question is well what the hell
is wrong with you
like why don't you see it and it's worse
than that like simon has done other
funny tricks like
imagine you went to a grocery uh store
and the cashier was behind the
counter right and you're talking to the
cashier and the cashier says excuse me
for a minute and then
kneel's down and then someone else
stands up and keeps talking to you
and you think oh you're going to catch
that and
you don't about 50 percent of people
miss that completely so you can like
change
the person completely and the reason is
well
how much processing do you have to do to
have
a casual interaction with a cashier at a
grocery store and the answer is
not much right you don't have to do the
processing doesn't have to be that deep
and you can kind of tell this because
you can watch the simpsons
or you can watch south park and south
park has like the world's worst
animation right i mean
everything moves like this it's all
circles and triangles and
you don't care it's like five minutes
into the narrative it doesn't matter
that it's circles and triangles having a
conversation
it's fine the icon will work and
that's that's a good rule for perception
is you use the simplest possible
perceptual scheme that you can manage
to get yourself from point a to point b
right it's a map you don't see the world
you see an iconic representation of the
world
and then the question is what makes the
iconic representation
sufficient and i suppose sufficient
means a couple of things one things it
means
it means is tolerable right it doesn't
cause an
excess of suffering and degeneration it
has to be functional
right and then and then maybe a more
specific example
of that would be well it has to work
like a map works a map is a low
resolution representation but
it's a good enough map if you use the
map and you start at point a
and you happen to be at point a which is
a good beginning for a map
and then you use the map and you get to
point b
and you think good enough map and and
that's really
that's that's us that's how we think
that's how we
that's how we construe the world our
maps are are really the stories that we
use in the world are really the maps we
use to guide us
and then they have perceptual
implications but that's essentially what
you do
so now the question is all right
what happened in the gorilla video well
what happened was you're aiming at
something
right you're aiming at counting the
the passes and the question is well why
were you doing that
and the answer is well someone told you
to asked you to and then you might ask
well
why did you listen to them there's lots
of other things you might have done in
the lab
but that isn't what you did you did what
you're asked to and we might say well
that's because you're
reasonably cooperative and civilized and
then we might say well
why is that a hallmark of cooper
cooperation and civilization and we
might say well
reciprocity like spontaneous reciprocity
between strangers who have a bit of a
contractual arrangement
is part of civilized behavior and so
that's the appropriate thing to do and
we might say well
you wanted to do a good job in the lab
because you wanted to make sure that
your status wasn't too low you know you
could count to 16 and so you can give
yourself a pat on the
back of the head for that and you know
it's part of being a
civilized person and so there's a huge
value structure
behind that like you didn't go into the
lab and shoot it up you know
you didn't bring a hand grenade right
and you didn't you didn't you didn't you
didn't
sexually assault the experimenter
there's lots of things you could have
done in there
and you didn't do those things you just
sat there and counted the
balls and missed the gorilla
okay so and there's complicated reasons
for that there are deep
reasons for that and so there are deep
reasons for
how you perceive things and why and so
that's what we're going to go into so
the first thing we're going to do is
talk about the basics of perception
and perception is very very tightly
related to
action to movement forward and to
emotion
and those things are very important to
know they're very they're very tightly
associated so for example
you live in a in a map let's say or a
story
and the story is um wherever i am isn't
as good as it could be and so i'm going
to go somewhere
that's somewhat better and you know that
can be of different time frames
maybe you've got a plan for the next
minute
you know you're hungry and so you want
to go somewhere to eat or maybe it could
be for the next hour or the next week or
the next day or the next year or
whatever but
basically what you're trying to do is
take where you are point a
and make it better point b and so you're
always somewhere that isn't quite as
good as it should be
and you're always going somewhere that's
somewhat better at least that's the hope
unless things have gone wrong you know
and you feel god it's nothing but
downhill from here on in
and that's not good you don't want that
that's a that's a pathological condition
so and it's kind of unfortunate in some
sense because it means you can't be
satisfied with what you've got but how
the hell can you be satisfied with what
you've got because
you've got problems coming your way you
know i mean
even if everything's okay right now
which it probably isn't
but even if it was that doesn't mean
everything's going to be okay tomorrow
or next week or next year or five years
from now right you've got the future to
take care of and
your future self and you've got your
family to take care of and
maybe you've got your community to take
care of so you've got some problems
and so the way things are isn't good
enough
and so you're going to fix them a bit
and so then you fix them across
different levels of resolution
and you do this you know if you do this
technically in this manner so you you
identify where you are one one thing you
might think about
is if you're mixed up one of the
problems you might have is that
you don't know where you are lots of
times people have to go to therapy
or or talk for a long time to someone to
find out where they are because
your experience might have scattered you
everywhere and you just
and you feel that things have that
you've come apart at the seams right the
things have fallen apart around you that
you're in chaos
you don't know where you are and and so
then you're in trouble because
how the hell are you going to plot a
course forward into the future if you
don't know where you are
and so maybe you have to bring yourself
up to date i have an exercise online by
the way at a place called self-authoring
which is called the past authoring
exercise um
fittingly enough and what it asks you to
do is to write an autobiography it's a
guided autobiography and it can kind of
bring you up to date
and you can know if you need to be
brought up to date it's fairly
straightforward
if you're obsessed by memories of the
past
more than 18 months old and most of
those are negative
so anxiety provoking most often then
there's a lot of you that's stuck in the
past and what that means is you didn't
map the territory well enough
and the parts of your brain that are
alarm systems anxiety systems are saying
no no there's holes in the way you're
looking at the world there's holes in
the way that you're looking in the world
and you fell in them once
and you don't know where they are and
you don't know how to fill them and you
don't know how to walk around them
and so you can't forget them you can't
forget them you can't forget them you
can't forget them
so you have recurring nightmares for
example are a good example of that
sort of thing happening but in in any
case if you have memories like that
you you remember them they make you feel
anxious and negative
you're stuck back there your body is
still reacting as if there's an
emergency
that could happen again that you haven't
fixed it doesn't matter if it was your
fault that's irrelevant because the
alarm system doesn't care
like when your smoke detector goes off
it isn't
relevant whether it was your fault the
smoke detector just says
house is on fire and that's a bad thing
and your anxiety systems are like that
if
if they're tagging old memories with
anxiety then
you have to do something about it or you
will be tortured by those memories
forever because that's how the alarm
system works and so maybe you need to go
back there and clean things up you got
to figure out okay well
how did this happen what sort of role
did i play
even if it's a minor role that doesn't
matter because the point is is that you
don't want to be put in the same
vulnerable position again
so anything you can do to strengthen
yourself is good you know and often if
it's a really old memory like maybe you
were a child it's you're not a child now
so you probably have a variety of
techniques at hand
that you could use to deal with a
situation like that if it came up now
and so
you have to update that part of your
brain that still thinks you're for
and lots of people have parts of them
that are still
stuck in some traumatic childhood
experience
and and they don't i had a friend like
that who had terrible childhood and and
i mean really
i've had clients with terrible
childhoods and his was like top of the
top of the lobster hierarchy in terms of
terrible childhoods and whenever he had
a dream
about it which was very often he was
five in his dream
he's 58 you know he's not five
but hadn't been updated and so he was
still five in his dreams it was a
complete bloody nightmares for him
complete with physiology all sorts of
terrible physiological symptoms really
hurting his life
he couldn't get himself updated and he's
he's much older in his dreams now by the
way he's up to about 45 so
that's a which is way better than five
you know because you can't fight back
when you're five
but you can fight back when you're 45
especially if you have some
you know some some experience at your
disposal so anyways
you need to know where you are so let's
say where you are
is well you're on this stage and you're
on this side of the stage
and you decide that you're going to go
over to that side of the stage
just to show that you can um and you're
making the decision
the same decision that you know the
famous chicken who is going to cross the
road
why does the chicken cross the road well
if it's a sensible chicken
it's because it assumes that there's
something better on the other side of
the road
it's like or maybe it's random curiosity
but then it just gets
picked off by a dingo or a coyote so
that's not so good
the other side of the road is better so
away the chicken goes so that's what
you're doing you're
going slum somewhere slightly better and
so
that's good technically it's good
because the way that your positive
emotion systems work they run on a
neural chemical called dopamine which by
the way is the
neurochemical system that drugs like
cocaine and methamphetamine and
alcohol for some people and opiates
affect dramatically
and make people feel far better than
they should
which is part of their danger it's a
very fundamental system
the dopamine system kicks in with a kick
of positive emotion
if you're going somewhere that's worth
going
and so that's worth knowing it's really
worth knowing it's like okay
you want a little bit of positivity in
your life well how do you get it well
you've got to get the system
it's almost the like it's the left
hemisphere system for for most people
not that that's particularly relevant
but it's a it
it is a standalone neurochemical system
it's rooted very very deeply in the
brain's exploratory circuitry
so very ancient ancient system and
it's happy when you have somewhere to go
that's the first thing and then it's
also happy when you're
going there and so if i'm on this side
of the stage
and i want to go over to that side of
the stage and i see that there's a nice
clear pathway
i could just go straight down this line
then i look at that and i'm actually a
little happy
i'm i'm not i'm not ecstatic i mean who
the hell cares if i get to the other
side of the stage right i mean
it's it's a small piece of my life but
it's not nothing
it's something okay and so i look at the
pathway
and i think that's a good pathway and i
feel a little positive
and then if i move here and then i see
that
uh little table right in the way between
me and
and the other side of the stage then i
feel a little negative
because i don't want an obstacle in my
pathway and so that's really how you're
looking at the world by the way
you don't see objects it's not the right
way to think about it we don't see
objects
and then think about them and then
evaluate them and then decide how to act
on them
or if we do we do it rarely and slowly
and with
a lot of thought what we see instead are
pathways
with tools that will move us forward or
obstacles
right and there's no obstacles here and
there's a nice flat
road and so great positive emotion way
uh there this is a task i can undertake
the sailing is clear it's a good day and
then i'm here and it's like
yeah well that's a little annoying
um i get a little pang of disappointment
let's say
anxiety can i make it around that
obstacle i'm fairly confident i've done
this sort of thing before
so i can take the rough route and i can
you know walk forward like this and then
i can do this great trick which is just
this and then you know i've circumvented
the obstacle
now if i didn't know how to do the
little bit of circumvention
then that would be a real problem right
because i couldn't get from point a to b
and that would screw up my plan but i do
have that particular skill set so it's a
minor
disruption to the perceptual set
that i'm using to organize the world
it's a minor bit of chaos
because that's what happens when your
perceptual set the structure that you're
using
to organize the world the plan through
which
you're viewing the complexity of the
world reveals
an inadequacy then that destabilizes
your emotions
so that's another thing to know one
thing you need to know is you need to be
going somewhere and there needs to be a
pathway
in order for you to feel good the other
thing to know is that
if that plan is untenable
or becomes destabilized then what
happens is you become flooded with
negative emotion
frustration disappointment anger
primarily anxiety but all of those
things
sort of intermingled anger maybe because
you have to fight your way through the
obstacle frustration because
maybe you have to make a new plan
disappointment because you put a bunch
of work into the damn plan
and it didn't work out anxiety because
now there's too many
choices in front of you and so people
don't like to have their plans
disrupted they don't like to have their
plans disrupted
and the reason for that is that their
plans are directly associated
with their emotional perception of the
world
and so and that that's a good thing to
know too that's why
you know what it is is you've decided
that you're going to go to like a korean
restaurant for
dinner and that's fine and then it turns
out that you can't and
maybe you have to go to a greek
restaurant and it's like who cares right
unless you hate greek restaurants um
korean restaurant that's pretty good
greek restaurant that's pretty good
you're still going to be annoyed that
your plans changed well why
because it's annoying to have your plans
changed it disrupts
the structure that you use to
destabilize to stabilize
your perceptions of the world and it
throws you momentarily
into a state of chaos not much
now how much chaos hmm this is
interesting
we don't know you know like let's say
you wake up one morning and you have an
ink in your side
it's like well you don't have an ache in
your side
what does it mean that you have an ink
in your side well you don't know
like maybe it means you pulled a muscle
and like who the hell cares maybe it
means you have cancer and like you're
going to be dead in six months
the whole range of possibility is there
you know and some people will assume one
thing it's like that's nothing and some
people will assume the other
and all of them will be right sometime
and so the question is how do you
calibrate something like that
and the answer is well we tend to guess
at it we guess at it temperamentally so
one way we guess at it is we have our
set points for negative emotion
so neuroticism traits some people will
be a lot more nervous about a small
level anomaly than others and maybe
they'll go to the hospital first
and they won't die and then or maybe
they'll be freaking out all the time and
there'll be a hypochondriac right so
there's
pros and cons about being nervous like
that other person is very
emotionally stable they don't worry
about much they think that's nothing and
then
you know by the time they get to the
hospital it's too late hey that's how
the dice roll
that's one way that you guess it's
determined in large part genetically not
completely but in large part
another part is your position in the
hierarchy
you know so the issue is how safe are
you in life
and the answer is who knows but
one of the way you guess is well are you
good at things
you know because if you're good at
things and a problem comes up you can
probably solve it
and then you might think well how do you
know if you're good at things and one
answer might be
well other people think you're good at
things because you're really kind of
comparing yourself to other people when
you're thinking about whether or not
you're good at things
and so if it turns out that you're in a
hierarchy and you're fairly high in the
hierarchy
indicating a certain degree of
competence then your nervous system
under the control of the serotonin
system dampens
down your negative emotion it says look
you know all things considered
you're probably pretty safe and that's
nice
but it also means you don't like having
your position in the dominance hierarchy
challenged
at all because if you get tossed down
the hierarchy let's say you get fired
what wreaks havoc with the your
serotonergic function
it makes you defeated like the defeated
lobsters that i wrote about
and then all of a sudden you're way more
susceptible
to negative emotion and who wants
that and so that's why you don't even
like to lose arguments
you know you lose a little argument it's
like whoop down the dominance hierarchy
a bit
emotions are a bit destabilized it's no
damn way i'm right
and why because i want to keep my
neurochemistry in check
and no wonder well the thing is
sometimes it's better to learn than to
insist upon being right
because learning works better for the
future but you get the point
okay so now i'm going to go from
this side of the room to the other side
and uh
that's my little journey and so but that
isn't exactly how journeys work they're
nested you know you've seen bullseyes
classical arrow you know archery
bullseyes i think
they're red in the middle usually right
and then there's a variety of colored
circles around them maybe the whole
bull's eye is this big
and you're supposed to hit the bullseye
but the closer you get to the center the
better but
at least you could hit part of it that
would be good you know
and you're supposed to stand back and
and pull your arrow back and aim
and so and that's that's that's that's
an acting out of something it's an
acting out of the necessity of
having an aim and taking your best shot
right that's what makes it a sport now
and if you think about that
most of our sports are like that right
soccer's like that rugby's like that
basketball is like that
hockey's like that almost all team
sports involve some sort of projectile
going to some sort of target and usually
people organize themselves into
hierarchies
two of them because there's two teams
and then they compete and cooperate to
get the projectile in the target and for
some reason
we think that's really cool right
well look it's worth thinking through
deeply it's like you'll spend a lot of
money
on on that opportunity to go into in
toronto
you can't buy nhl tickets for the maple
leafs they're unbelievably expensive and
they've been sold out forever even
though the damn team hasn't won a
championship since like 1968.
doesn't matter people will spend a
fortune to go sit
in an arena like a long way away from
the
from the action and there there's these
guys out there and they're tough and
they're fast and they're fighting with
this little
black frozen disc and they're trying to
get it in a net
well someone is trying to stop it's
completely bloody absurd
and yet people are thrilled about it
they're thrilled and they'll pay for it
right they don't have to be dragged
they're kicking and screaming like they
line up it's oh god a hockey game
thank god and they'll wear the jerseys
it's like and then
you know some some character who's put
in his ten thousand dollars does his
beautiful move and
puts in a goal in some manner that's
like technically impossible and
everybody leaps to their feet and they
just have a fit of
joy and you think what in the world is
going on
with that it's like you're happier when
that happens than you were when you got
married it's like you don't see well you
don't see people doing that when they're
and then it's not everybody when you get
married and everybody stands up and has
a little like
like a a ten-minute fit and hugs
strangers and then
goes out and drinks a dozen beer and has
a riot and tears down stores
it's like no no but uh but a good goal
that'll do it
i think i think guatemala and ecuador
went to
war over a soccer game literally
so so and let's not assume we're so
stupid you know even though we are
um let's not assume it is there's
something behind this it's like
we really like to see people take
careful aim and hit the target
and we really like to see them cooperate
and compete in an expert manner to do
that
and we really like to see them do that
in a way that
stretches their ability beyond what we
would normally be able to see right
because
it's nice to go to a competent display
of athletics
but now and then you go you see these
like soccer goals
on youtube where these crazy characters
you know they flip around in the air
and they're like eight feet off the
ground completely backwards and they
kick the ball four feet to the side of
the goalie it's just
it's just impossible like they're 100
yards away and it's perfect
and you think right on that's what a
human being is like
and you're not really like that because
you couldn't do it but
you are human and conceivably you could
do
something like that and so it's a nice
display of that
potential for us to hit the damn target
right so then the question is well
what's the target and that's the
question because that's the same
question as
what's the meaning and so okay so here's
my target let's say let's
do a personal unpacking of my value
system
at least at least in part so i'm a
writer
and and i'm a writer and a researcher
and a clinician
and and and a professor so those things
in
maybe roughly in that order and so
that's that's my
claim to my position in the social
hierarchy and
you know the claim is something like i'm
competent at that
it's worthwhile therefore i'm reasonably
entitled by the rules of the game
to the privileges and statuses that are
associated with that position
right as long as i'm competent so
there's a match between social
demand and my ability and as long as i'm
playing the game properly
then i'm safe that's what's keeping my
emotions regulated
it's not my internal regulation it's the
fact that i can do what i say i can do
and everyone else agrees and people
value that and that keeps me secure
that's also why i don't want too much
social upheaval you know because i might
end up with the same
skill set in a society that doesn't
value those skills and then
well then what then i'm done so i want
there to be an isomorphism between
my internal hierarchy of perceptual
value
and the social structure itself you know
and so this is also partly why
radical claims of multiculturalism are
wrong
because at the base of things we need to
be playing a unified game
so that everybody knows what everybody
else is up to
doesn't mean that diversity of opinion
isn't useful because
now and then the collective claim is
going to be wrong
and need to be updated and so you need
some strange people around
creative people generally speaking who
will you know take things in a direction
that's novel
to update but roughly speaking we want
everybody nested in the same game and
then maybe above that playing some
different games
and we need that because it's the only
way we can orient ourselves in the world
it's the only way we can keep a match
between our expectations and our skills
and our desires
and what's actually expected of us in
the world there's nothing
that's more harmful than for you to play
the game straight
right to do what you're supposed to do
to be a good person and then to be
punished for it instead of rewarded
very disheartening you want what you
think to be good and right to
also be rewarded by the world in that
manner
and that means the structures have to be
the social structure and the
psychological structure
have to match and part of the reason
that we protect our cultures
is so that we can protect the match
between our psychological structures and
our social structures
and keep ourselves oriented moving
forward in the world with some positive
emotion
and not terrified out of our skulls it's
crucially important
it's why it's why we'll fight to protect
what we've built
it's the game we understand it's not
something that can just be arbitrarily
shifted or changed and that's partly
because the aim isn't arbitrary
the aim isn't arbitrary this is the
problem with the post-modernists and
the moral relativists they don't know
what the hell they're talking about
they're 100 years out of date they've
got it wrong
okay so so i'm typing
and when i'm typing i'm moving my
fingers right and that's not thinking
that's moving my fingers and i don't
really know how i move my fingers
but i can do it and i can do it on a
keyboard and so
i can type letters one at a time and so
you might say well what are you doing
if you were watching me and i'd say well
i'm typing letters that's my aim
so i'm pretty happy when i hit an a and
an a appears
and i'm not that happy when i hit an and
e appears and i have to backspace a
little annoyance there right because
i've shifted off the target a little
frustration i fix it that's okay
back on track but i'm not typing letters
because like who wants to read a bunch
of letters
no one you want to read words so i'm
trying to organize
the letters into words so goal 1 is the
letters
nested inside goal 2 which is the words
but you don't want just random words
that's not helpful
how about some phrases that'd be good
how about some sentences
letters words phrases sentences now
we're starting to get into units of
meaning
right and those are directions they're
like a map
they have a point like a book has a
point like a story has a point and the
point is to outline the map
properly and they're not just sentences
paragraphs
and those are organizations of sentences
that make the sentences
make sense and the phrases and the words
and the letters
all nested together and not just
paragraphs chapters
right and then chapters nested in a
whole book and then not just the whole
bloody book
because that's not enough the book
itself has to be nested in
the shared literary experience of the
audience i have to assume
if i'm writing a book that there's a
certain amount of culture
that we share because otherwise i'd have
to explain absolutely everything about
absolutely everything
and i can't and so the book doesn't work
unless it's in a culture that's composed
of
maybe a thousand books in some sense
that are widely known by
all of us even if we haven't read them i
can assume that the reader
is a mechanism that can understand what
i've written and that's part of where
the meaning is too
and so that's all nested together all of
that to make
it meaningful for me to sit down in the
morning and
concentrate so foolishly in some sense
on moving my fingers up and down on a
keyboard
right what's meaningful about that well
nothing
who cares if i type a letter a single
letter yeah well how about a word how
about the right word how about the right
phrase how about the right sentence well
every movement outward more broadly
makes it more meaningful
and if that whole structure is coherent
then all of the small actions become
associated with the meaning of all of
the large scale actions right
i'm not just typing letters i'm writing
a book
why okay then we get broader this is
still this is the bullseye
this is the structure of the bullseye
the center might be the letter
you know that's one way of looking at it
that's the highest resolution thing i've
got to get that exactly right and then
it's nested inside all of these other
structures
well i'm an educator okay so i'm hoping
the book will be educational well why
well because maybe it would be better
for people to be educated than not to be
so that they don't have to suffer so
stupidly and so they could be less
malevolent and that the world would be a
less brutal place
that would be all right so that's part
of my goal i'm a clinician i want to
fulfill that part of my moral obligation
to justify my privileged position
in the social hierarchy right i'm a
scientist i want to test my hypothesis
and see if they're correct so i can
advance
the scientific domain and push human
knowledge a little bit farther out into
the unknown
right and i'm doing that maybe because i
want to be a good person something like
that
okay so so now we're now we're a long
ways out in the moral hierarchy and so
now we might think about
what does it mean to be a good person
does that mean something
well you think it does
because you know people who are good
people and you know people who aren't
good people and you make a qualitative
distinction between them
and you know when you're being a good
person and when you're not and you make
a qualitative distinction between that
too
so i don't think we have to have a
discussion about whether or not good
and bad people exist it's we might have
a discussion about how you
distinguish between them but that's a
different issue so here's some here's
some ideas
and this is what we'll end off with um
what does a good person do they take
care of themselves
that's a good thing you know you don't
want to be a burden to anyone else
sometimes you're going to have to be but
most of the time maybe it'd be better if
you were a net positive
you know and rely on people when you
have to and so that means
don't be so damn useless and constrain
some of your malevolence
and that that's a good meaty bloody war
to
get involved in it's not trivial it
gives you something to do when you get
up in the morning
and then it might be the same with your
social organization your family
it's like your family could use some
work man just like everybody's family
and
you might be able to help and the
company you work for same thing
blind willfully blind stupid corrupt
going in the wrong direction not
entirely you know
i mean things work pretty well for how
haphazard the world is in some sense i'm
not trying to be overly pessimistic and
i'm certainly not claiming that we live
in an oppressive patriarchy but
like there's work to do in most
organizations a little honesty and a
little hard work on your part might
straighten that thing out just a little
bit and god only knows what the
consequences of that would be across
time
and then you know there's natural
worries that you might
want to take care of there's diseases to
conquer and and there's children to take
care of and there's food to provide and
and all of the things that go along with
that so that you could involve yourself
in taming and regulating the natural
world
that would be a good thing so so there's
three sources of meaning
right get yourself under control see
what you can do about the tyranny of
culture
and see what you can do about the
civilization of nature right
that's the construction of a walled
garden that's what paradise means to get
the balance between civilization
and nature right that's your goal so
people can live in there and peace and
harmony
including you that's a good goal and
then you think well that's going out
quite a ways you know
you're the culture hero who's taking on
your own
malevolence and ignorance the tyranny of
your culture and the cruelty of nature
great we need more people like you go
for it
and then maybe we can go one stage
outside of that and this is as far as i
can go with it
so here's how i think we are
you know you hear scientists talk about
us as deterministic creatures
we're causal like an alarm clock you
wind the thing up of course you don't
anymore but you wind the thing up and it
just ticks
away and it and one thing follows
another it's like
we're actually not like that you build
systems of habit
so here's an example if i go like this
that's a ballistic movement and i have
to plan that movement
from here to here before i execute it
because the movement is so fast
that i can't get a neural message from
my hand to my brain and back
to stop it once it started so the whole
thing is
deterministic i plan it let it go it's
deterministic
but i know how to do this it's habit i
have a structure built in me that's
deterministic
and lots of things you do are like that
habit
anything you practice enough it's habits
so you're deterministic at the habit
level but
you're not deterministic at the level of
consciousness
because consciousness comes into play
when you're doing something that you
haven't done
before and now so that's interesting
because what it means is the conscious
you
is dealing with the world that isn't
determined
yet and i would say it's actually
dealing with the world of possibility
the world of potential and it's a world
we believe in you say to people
you're not living up to your potential
and you say that to yourself too you
know when you wake up at night and
you're guilty i'm not living up to my
potential and you don't feel good about
that
and you think well there's potential
around you that you're not exploiting
you know and you feel bad about that too
and you should
and so it's a good source of guilt and
shame not enough to crush you maybe but
enough to wake you up and it's certainly
not something you hope for for the
people that you love
ah it's okay you're wasting your
potential it doesn't matter
it's like no one says that and so what
we're contending with potential
and we know that because we wake up in
the morning and poof we're awake like
the sun
has risen again we're awake and we
confront the world and
what do we confront we confront the
possibilities the potential and the
horror of the day
here's the things we could do here's the
things that could go bad
here's how we could make things go
better and you know what that is it's
usually
ah there's three or four things that i
need to do today that i'd rather avoid
but i better do them because if i don't
do them the world will be a worse place
by six o'clock tonight right and that's
a funny thing because
the world isn't like that yet it isn't
made like that yet
it won't be made like that until you
make it and you might think well here's
some things i could do that would be
good that would actually make the world
a better place by six o'clock tonight
take some effort you know and the
willingness and some aim
but you could do that you could make it
slightly better than it was and
certainly
slightly less worse than it could be
and and you know that it weighs on you i
would say as soon as you wake up it
might be a moral burden or it might be
excitement or it might be some
combination of both
but certainly how you view yourself a
conscious agent
confronting what has not yet been
brought
into being confronting potential and
determining the course that the world's
going to take
maybe just in your small area but who
knows how big your area
is and how much what you do echoes
around you you know
we have an idea in our culture that each
of us is the center of the world
that's why you're the you're you're part
of the sovereign state that's why you
vote that's why the
future of the state itself is dependent
on your
decision because we've decided over like
a ten thousand year period that your
king you for whatever for whatever
reasons it's
on you your conscious ability to be
awake and to be articulate
and to and to be clued in and to keep
nature at bay and culture straight and
your own malevolence under check
and to combat the unknown and to
transform it into something that's good
that's what you are and you see this
reflected in the oldest stories that's
the dragon myth you know
you go out into the terrible unknown
beyond what we understand
into the unknown itself and you confront
the terrible
thing that rests there the terrible
predatory
eternal predatory monster and you can do
that because that's what you're like
you're not cowering
at home you're not frozen into
submission you're out there
active and you can take it on and as a
consequence you can attain something of
substantive
value right and then that's you that's
the transformation of you because now
you're braver because you've done it but
it's also something now that you've
you've
garnered from the potential and you can
bring that back and you can distribute
that
into the community that's the story of
humanity
it's the oldest story we have
and it's correct there's this idea in
genesis
i'll end with this so there's this idea
in genesis that at the beginning of time
there was potential tohu there was
potential
it was nothing like like the nothing
that's there when you wake up in the
morning that's
just the potential of the day it's all
sorts of things that could be but
nothing that is
and then there's a structure that
confronts it well that's you
there you are the structure that
confronts potential and then there's the
personality that you use to confront it
so in in genesis the personality is
logos and it's something like
truthful courage and communicative
ability
all amalgamated it's something like that
so and it's a it's a it's a lesson it's
like okay
there's the potential what are you
supposed to do with it well there you
are
ready to confront it how do you confront
it with truth
and courage and then you transform it
into
what exists you take the potential you
transform it into being itself
that's your job in genesis when god does
this repeatedly
he says something repeatedly he says
after each day of doing this and it was
good
i mean and it's repeated so it's like it
means something it's repeated
what does it mean if you confront
potential
with truth and courage then what you
produce is good
well so that's a good thing to know if
you want to produce what's good it's
like
confront the potential with truth and
courage and what you produce is
good great so that's a that's a nice
thing to know it's a fundamental ethical
axiom
and it's sort of predicated on faith
it's not easy to be courageous
and it's not easy to tell the truth but
the theory is if you manage both of
those in the face of potential then what
you do is you produce out of potential
what is good so that's a
theory worth investigating perhaps for
the rest of your life
and then there's a corollary to this
story and the story is
at the end of god's creation describing
how
order emerges from chaos or being from
potential
there's this strange line which is
probably the most important line
that's ever been written in our culture
at the basis of our culture and that is
that men and women are made in the image
of god
and what does that mean well if god is
that which confronts potential with
truth and courage
and makes what's good out of potential
that seems to indicate that we have the
same faculty like
on a smaller scale we're not omniscient
but we're not bloody well
nothing you know our conscious is
integrally tied into the structure of
being in some manner we don't understand
and it certainly is the case that we
take what isn't
and turn it is into what is that's
something man that's that's quite the
trick we've been able to manage
and so we're made in that image and so
what are we supposed to do
well that's what we're supposed to do
we're supposed to type our letters and
make our phrases and construct our
sentences
and build our paragraphs and put our
chapters together and make our books and
communicate to people
and straighten out the damn culture and
constrain the malevolence and ignorance
that besets each of us
and push nature back and extend
ourselves out into the unknown
and confront the potential that's there
in the illimitable
quantities and make the world better
than it could be
otherwise to move it away from hell
which
and it can certainly become that and
toward heaven
to the degree that we can manage that
and that
is a good enough goal that's the thing
you need something you know because your
life is tough it's hard
you need something that you know you
need something to get out of bed for and
fight for
and that's something right to fight
let's say
against hell and for heaven
not something to fight for
especially
and you know if you if you don't if you
want to be convinced about this
like read a little bit about hell read
the gulag archipelago or read ordinary
men
or read the rape of nan king or read
about what happened in nazi germany
during auschwitz and
all the catastrophes of the 20th century
and see if you believe in hell
and see if you think well maybe not
having that happen anymore would be a
good idea
and then think about maybe that's
something you could contribute to
and then it wouldn't have to happen
anymore
and that would be a good thing and god
only knows what great things we could
manage under such conditions were
becoming incredibly technologically
powerful
and what would it be if we became what
would it be like if we became equally
wise
well that would really be something god
only knows what we could manage in the
next 20 years or the next 100 years you
know
we're running at 40 most of us you know
because we're half in and half out
and it's not surprising because life is
difficult it's like well what if you
were 90
in or 95 in or or
all in because you're all in anyways
right
it's a it's a life and death game no one
gets out of this
everyone dies you might as well commit
yourself
and you might as well commit yourself to
the highest good that you can attain
because
why not it'll imbue your life with
meaning it's hard the responsibility is
there
but all the meanings in the
responsibility and that'll make your
life
better it'll make your family's life
better and it should make your culture
better maybe it make the world better
it's like that'll justify your damn
miserable existence at three o'clock in
the morning when you're wondering what
the hell you're doing here
and that's a good thing because there's
going to be days when you're aching and
tired and sore
and there's people in your family that
are sick and you're cynical and bitter
and you need a reason to get up and you
think yeah well
a little more heaven and a little less
hell maybe i can pull that off today and
tomorrow and next week
and that's worth struggling forward for
and so that's how it looks to me so
thank you very much
[Applause]
how much better does it get than this my
friend yeah well
it's pretty nice to be here that's for
sure and see everybody around here even
these people who keep looking at me from
behind
all right all right i know we want to do
as many as possible tonight so here we
go
i thought this was a good first one will
you please
please please run for prime minister of
australia
well that's a very inviting offer
and um somewhat embarrassing i would
i would say not because there's anything
wrong with your country by the way
um i am pretty happy doing what i'm
doing at the moment
and so i'm talking to politicians in
canada and the us
and in other countries and doing what i
can in some small way to
moderate the excess degree of
polarization that seems to be
characterizing our discourse at the
moment and
and right now that seems to be a good
position to be in
and this is good like i i can't see at
the moment
doing anything with my life that is
more useful and effective than this and
so i'm going to try to do
the things that i think are most useful
and effective and
and this is it at the moment so for now
i'm writing another book as well and
it's coming along quite well
it should be out next january with any
luck and so i'm trying to keep that
going but
at the moment this is but i appreciate
the sentiment
by the way
what are the most important things we
should be teaching young children
in schools
well to play fair that's the most
important thing that you can teach
children
because the fundamental ethic like the
ground of ethics is
fair play and children practice that
while they're playing and so a lot of
what should be happening in schools
is play by children
a fair bit of it's spontaneous
especially when they're very young
but regulated by adults so that it
remains fair
right that it remains reciprocal and you
can tell that because
children will continue to play a game if
they believe the game is fair
when the game stops being fair then it
breaks down into squabbling and crying
which is what our games are breaking
down into right now
right and so then you need a mediator
who comes in
and adjudicates as well you know how
about if you try it this way maybe we
need to adjust the rule let's see if we
can get the game going again
it's very important for for kids to
learn how to play fair
and i'm afraid that a fair bit of our
electronic technology is taking them
away
from the kinds of social interactions
that they need to
learn one-on-one to know how to play
fair i might be wrong about that because
i don't know what effect video games
have and the
the evidence that they're bad isn't
strong you know
and and they're new so we really don't
know so that might be good enough but
that and well it'd be good to teach kids
to read
we seem to be continually confused about
whether or not that's a good
idea but we actually do know how to
teach kids to read you can use phonics
pro
programs and i believe computers can
speed that along substantially
be good to teach them to read it's good
to teach them to write
it's good to encourage them you know
that's another thing
it's a good thing if you it's a good
thing to know this just generally here's
a real powerful technique that you might
want to think about man because this is
this is worth knowing
um you know often when you have a family
member
or someone that you're interacting with
and they make a mistake then you call
them out on their mistake
and it's pretty obvious when they make a
mistake because you're going along on a
pathway together
and then there's a divergence from the
pathway and you notice that that's
negative emotion
and you say you know what the hell
what's going on
what you don't notice is all the time
you're spending walking forward
when it's going real well and the reason
for that is what's going real well so
you mostly ignore it
but that's not so good you got to wise
up
um the the behavioral psychologist b.f
skinner was very smart person he noticed
when he was training animals that the
best way to train an animal was to wait
until the animal did something you
wanted it to do
and then reward it now you had to watch
eh
but and you had to know what you wanted
the animal to do
that's the other thing so you had to be
smarter than the animal
um so like if you're dealing with people
in your own life or yourself
for that matter and you notice that the
person that you're with or
are has done something that
you would like to see repeated many
perhaps many times you might want to
point it out
say look you know i just saw you do this
thing and um
i'm really happy about that you did it
you did a great job
i'm really happy about that a little
more of that would be wonderful
and and just leave it be and people are
very thrilled about that because
they're and this is especially true of
kids is there
they are looking for positive attention
they're looking for attention
period that's their currency they'll
take negative attention if they can't
get positive attention
they really want positive attention and
what they really want
is for someone to watch them and notice
when they do something that makes them a
good
person and then have that pointed out
it's like
good work kid way to be i saw what you
did
here's what it was good job i'm sure you
could do a bunch more of that
then they're just like they're just
thrilled that
that that their action their small
child action was important enough to
draw your focused attention toward
that makes them glow and the probability
that that will
help them continue to act in those ways
is extremely
extremely uh powerful so you know if
you're trying to get along with some kid
adolescent maybe because they're kind of
hard to get along with
often you know watch them and if they do
something that's
it doesn't even have to be good it just
has to be better than what they're
usually doing
that you know which which is not a bad
approximation of good you know it's like
look i noticed that you you know you
were
you were more pleasant tonight at the
dinner table or
maybe that's not quite the way of
phrasing it because it's sort of an
insult to the way they are before you
might say
well because you have to be careful
right when you when you say these things
and not put a barb in it because you're
kind of irritated
you you might say um
it was it was it wasn't it was enjoyable
having dinner with you tonight
you know and they'll kind of clue in to
why that might be and they'll think oh
well you know
hey it turns out to matter if i do
something that's positive and so
that's that's that's a that's a piece of
information
about keeping your eyes open so well so
what do we do with kids let them play
make them play fair
that's really important teach them to
read that'd be good teach them to write
that'd be good teach them to stand up
and speak for themselves
that would be good you can teach a child
to stand up
pretty convincingly and say something
intelligent in about 15 minutes if you
do it carefully and it almost never
happens in school it's really it's
really quite appalling
so that's another thing you can do for
your kids is get them to
stand up and say something and you know
not
not like this talking to the floor and
barely able to hear
you know so that people have to strain
and and strive to hear them but to stand
up and to say
something and you can tell them well
stand up a little more
you know put your shoulders back a
little more a little more volume so i
can hear you
it can be a little game god they learn
that so fast you can hardly believe it
and
i don't know why they're not taught that
i think i think because people are
afraid
of competence and so they're afraid to
teach kids to be competent
and so we don't and and and they kind of
have to learn it
on their own and that's
unfortunate let's say
all right equally as important who would
win
in an mma match
you were sam harris
ah sam would win objectively but i would
win metaphysically
well played that sounded like a setup
but thank you did not set that up
what tips would you give a highly
emotional person
to become more rational and level-headed
oh well um
it depends there's a variety of the
first thing i would do if you're highly
emotional
like highly emotional volatile fly off
the handle
a lot of mood variation a lot of
negative emotion
um the first thing you might want to
think about is whether or not
there's actually something wrong with
you like physically you might be ill
because illness can do that to people
and so you should go get yourself
checked out you know you might have an
inflammatory condition or something like
that
that and the next thing i would check
out is like
um sure are you sure you're not hungry
i'm dead serious about this i mean with
with many of my clients who've been
anxious like a lot of them they come in
i'm so anxious i'm so anxious i had this
one client
she'd come in and she'd say god you know
i'm just i'm so dead at the end of the
day i'm
i'm just wiped out i've got no energy at
all all i can do is lay down she was
like 24.
all i can do is lay down and watch like
the same movie i watched the night
before
is that normal i was like well no it's
not
so and i and i and i knew this i said
well what do you eat
and she said well i usually don't have
any breakfast and then i have like a
little bowl of rice for lunch and
i usually have something like that for
for dinner
and i thought
you live on two balls of rice a day
and you're wondering why when you come
home at night after a full day's work
you don't have any energy i said well
have you considered the possibility that
you're starving to death
so you know we talked about they said
you can't you can't
live like that that that's not going to
work how about let's try this for a week
you do this with therapy you do
experiments if you're a behavioral
therapist it's like
you ought to come to an agreement with
the person it's like look
is there some other things you'd eat
other than rice
you know like four other things it's
like we agreed maybe she'd eat an egg or
something it's like
or or i think it was eggs and and i
think
i don't remember what it was there was a
few other things i said okay look here's
what you do
get up in the morning and like have two
eggs
you don't have to enjoy them you know
because people say well i'm not hungry
it's like
what why is that relevant that's not the
issue here
it isn't like gourmet time it's not
starving to death time
so eat your two eggs and maybe in three
months you'll enjoy it you know until
then it'll be like
chewing down rubbery cardboard but it's
not that big a deal
so you know we upped her caloric intake
by a factor of about
four and she came back and it was like i
think she came back two more times
it's like oh i have lots of energy now
it's like oh good
you're not dying of starvation it's like
and i'm telling you like if you're a
volatile person
if you're a volatile person try this eat
a high protein
high fat meal in the morning no sugar
and a big one like have a steak have
something solid
and don't doesn't matter if you like it
who cares cook it the night before
if if you don't want to cook it then
just try it for a week
and see what happens my suspicions i've
had half my clients i would say have
dropped their
volatility levels 50 percent by eating a
high fat high protein breakfast
and then also notice that if you are
crabby you know and volatile and touchy
and you can't get along with anyone
um go eat something like have two
teaspoons of peanut butter
and wait 10 minutes and see if you're
still a witch
so it so for some people and then if you
are a volatile person like your
your blood sugar levels tend to move up
and down more because you stress
yourself out more
for some people that really matters and
so look try it for a week
it's nothing right and you might think
oh god what you'll find if it works is
a you don't get nearly as upset about
the things that used to upset you
so and that'll be a shock you'll think
oh my god i would have flown off the
handle because of that before and now
it's hardly bothering me
so that's a lovely thing and and then
the second thing is
if something bothers you you'll recover
way faster
and so that's a good start and so try
that that's
that's no harm it's not going to hurt
you um try getting up at the same time
every day
that's really important if your sleep
wake cycle is not
regular and you're a volatile person say
biochemically genetically
having a sleep wake cycle that's
dysregulated is going to be very hard on
you so
it doesn't matter quite as much when you
go to bed although it would be good to
regularize that too but at least pick a
time
you can pick whatever time you want like
i would recommend like 8 o'clock or 7
30 because that's what normal people do
and unless you have a really good reason
not to be a normal person
you should start by trying to be a
normal person if you're being an
abnormal person
so try to get up at the same time and
try that you can combine that with
eating
and see like my suspicions are 50
improvement
virtually immediately with that and then
if that doesn't work well then there are
more serious things than that you can
consider being checked out by an md and
make
making sure you're okay you might want
to go talk to a therapist you might want
to consider something like
an ssri an anti-antidepressant because
maybe
maybe you have a biological condition a
biochemical condition
that's wreaking havoc with your mood
and like ssris serotonin reuptake
inhibitors
don't work for everyone my experience
has
been that they don't really work that
well for people who have
cataclysmically horrible lives
and that's not the same as being
depressed right
depressed is when actually your life's
not too bad by
normative standards but you're still
volatile as hell and your moods
out of out of kilter ssris sometimes can
help amazingly with that
and usually you'd know within a month so
try them for a month if they don't work
stop if they do work
well thank your lucky stars because how
bloody much misery do you want and
like having dysregulated negative
emotion is no
picnic man and it's really hard on the
people around you as well
so those are the that and
you know i have this program online i
mentioned the other thing you could try
is go online i have this program called
future authoring
you could do the past authoring program
and bring yourself up to date but future
authoring is a program that
helps you make a plan for your life you
know and what do you want from your
friends your family
your career your education how are you
going to take care of yourself mentally
and physically
where would you like to be in three to
five years how are you going to regulate
temptation drug and alcohol use and that
sort of thing you know keep yourself out
of trouble
and how are you going to stop yourself
from deteriorating to where you could
deteriorate
if you weren't careful takes you can do
a credible job of the program in an hour
and a half
you know it's proved very useful for
people maybe you're kind of aimless and
you need a plan
that's another possibility so but don't
live with
it you know there's lots of things you
can try
sleep that might be number one food
that's number two number three talk to
someone
a professional if it's really out of
hand because you what do you want to do
you want to suffer
terribly for the next 10 years and plus
if you do have a lot of excess negative
emotion
it's really hard on you
psychophysiologically because you
produce a lot of stress hormones and
that makes you
old so it's dangerous physically as well
so and it's hard on your brain so if you
can get it fixed
fix it and if it has to be medication
then
look man everybody's you're going to be
taking medication at some point in your
damn life
you know because you're going to get
sick and my observation of people has
been
that a everybody gets sick and then what
happens
well this is eliminating
random luck some people get sick and
then they do
everything they can to not be sick
including taking medication doing
whatever they have to
and some of them get better and others
just
they don't deal with it and
usually they don't get better so you
swallow your pride and you think oh yeah
i should be able to handle my problems
myself it's like yeah well
maybe you should but maybe you know if
you're really depressed
and you don't take an ssri then one day
you jump off a building
and that's pretty much the end of you
helping yourself
and so you know you can take the the
drug
hopefully it'll help you out you can get
your life back in order if you're
fortunate
then you can go off it you can taper off
it they're relatively
harmless weight gain's a problem some
suppression of sexual function
that's a problem you know so they're not
without
risk but neither is anything else so
those are
those are relatively straightforward
things that you can do that have a high
probability of working
this ain't much of a segue but when did
you become a middle-aged male
fashion icon
i love questions like this because it's
like they got the smartest guy around
well it's fun
it's it's one of the things that's been
fun about this tour is that a lot of
people dress up for it
i've seen more people in three-piece
suits than than you can imagine
in the last year and that's really fun
you see all these young guys they're
coming to these and not just young guys
coming to these shows and they're all
dressed up in three-piece suits it's
like they look like adults
it's kind of interesting because that's
gone out of fashion
so anyways when i i'd been buying some
reasonably high quality clothing i
suppose
when i was working as a professor
lecturing because i like to
dress professionally you know i thought
it was good ideas especially when i was
much younger because
it also helped put a bit of a
distinguishing
barrier between me and the students who
weren't the graduate students who
weren't much younger than me but i
always felt that it was a mark of
respect to the class
to dress professionally but then when
this tour started i thought well i might
as well up my game because
uh hypothetically i'm going to be
talking to you know
who god only knows how many people and i
might as well
i'm in it all the way man and so i
thought i might as well
buy some decent clothes and see what
happened and it was a really good idea
as it turned out i spent
more money than i thought any reasonable
human being should ever spend on
clothing
you know it really made me cheap
northern albertan that i was
you know used to ripped jeans and like
checked
shirts um i felt very guilty about doing
it but
but it was a really good idea and so
so
all right one more i want it to be a
good one here
would you ever smoke a blunt with reuben
or rogan
i might but i'm not going to tell you
people about it all right i guess we're
having a good time tonight um
on that note this is actually i'm i'm
actually going back to the states and
you're continuing the tour so this is
our last show out of 130
mod shows until we start up again in
september right
and i've said it privately to you many
times but this has been the
the professional and in many ways
personal journey of my life i
i can't thank you enough for being part
of this and it's weird to do it in front
of all these people but
[Music]
yes well thank you it's been you've been
you've been a great help it's been
light-hearted i've enjoyed the
introductions it's nice to face an
audience that's warmed up
i've enjoyed the q and a's we've we've
traveled all over it's gone extremely
smoothly
it's been a hell of a good thing all
together so thank you as well
on that note i'm getting out of here
guys make some noise for dr jordan
peterson
thank you guys very much